oh it's not starting here it is starting
right here I think can you see it
are you able to see it right there the
time man I got a faster huh this is not
standard play anymore is it
how am i playing this why am I playing
this line pawn push now I'll do it
pawn push and then one throw a knight in
here trickiness trickiness trickiness
trickiness I'll be made if it's taken
right here get back here with check
where that checks it's not pawn gonna
push trickiness trickiness and that
bishop where does that mean where does
that mean 30 seconds
mm-hmm okay okay focus now tricky Forks
are around every corner this has to be
made really soon where is this me that's
me finally capacitor felt like there's
there's like a bunch of mates that I was
missing along the way there okay okay
it's perfect thanks for the feedback on
the clock
all right oh I can't double the points
though I gotta get that thing out of my
way I'm not gonna be going back and
forth with that I can't have it I can't
have it why am I playing the
nimzo-indian what happened to fishing
pole broken broken let's try this take
my night take my night trickiness
trickiness take like that whoa that was
almost the adobe flash gambit that was
almost the adobe flash gambit this is
this is silly
setup here that I have going on what is
my night think he's doing hahaha
what's he think it's tickling oh man
okay I got to keep things closed I'll be
dead this is an okay structure isn't it
all right take like this
still the take like that I'm on the
night okay Bishop a6 still take like
this I'm guarding b7 which is an
important detail I'm on the knight twice
okay I want to double rooks can I get
that in double rooks double trouble
double it works double trouble it's
gonna take here take here no no the
night might take my pawn I get the night
with check and the rub probably and the
other ruck with check everything's
following no time 15 seconds just throw
my bishop in here not there right here
no time less than 10 free moves I don't
want any time to come out of the clock
any time in no time no time no time prey
moves
Primo's Primo's pre moves they're gone
on time back to tournament twelve twelve
ten nine I have six twenty five minutes
remaining
oh man here we go
round three yeah I can't I can't have
that little ticker there I needed uh I
need to be able to double those points
we might have a fishing pole it might
happen in disguise in disguise it might
happen right here might happen Castle no
it's being sniffed out it's being
sniffed out okay that night can I get
this file I'm gonna close it up all
right I want to get to g7 now weak point
g7 might want to if this now just go
back to open this up over here to keep
going I want to throw my knight in there
with Jack especially right now the rook
is not protected oh no it's not my
protected now but I'm still gonna do it
open this up like that then they has to
recapture and then jump my knight in
here take this knight first and then
throw this in here and now I want to get
that pawn throwing to check just so the
King can't castle and then do this yeah
I'm on that Bishop right now Bishop here
as well is not long off
right here first and then come back with
another tempo I believe no I could take
the take the bishop but I'm gonna do
this I want to get this pawn rollin pawn
push and then Bishop here somehow is
working maybe I broke over here now
let's stop knight there let's get that
rook active the King has stopped there
rook is stuck as well okay my bishop is
active they don't have any time no time
no time just do anything right here
they're out of time they're out of time
back determine 20 2017 12 23 minutes
remaining
okay I need what I need to sneak in a
quick kill I need to get a quick kill
where are they get that pawn I'm gonna
grab it and run away see if it was worth
it let's see if it was worth it that's
gonna be the big question whoa that's a
bit scary isn't it all right let's get
developed here whoa that's still scary
oh that's not that one was not scary
okay let us just castle I know the
Queen's off that's not count
that's not castle you're not canceled
when you move your queen remember that
it's important detail right there you're
never castled if you move you're clean
if you move your queen that's not
considered castling don't ever do it
okay ah anything right here I'm up peace
I am up a piece I'm up two pieces
Queen trade Queen win drop in pieces
they resigned back determine thirty
twenty seven twenty twenty twenty two
minutes remaining
Jackson eighty-eight all right French no
no no no no okay we're having something
sneaky here sneak attack
night block the kings run for the hills
may have one threat
take my bishop in 1a b5 that's me back
to tournament 30 30 30 27 20 22 minutes
remaining
okay who's this guy
whoa triple 100 we could have it no
they're gonna get that in our thing okay
let's take here and actually the night
has two block to defend this pawn it's
not I'm on the rook on the roof there's
Bishop checks as well
rook is dropping Knights powered I think
I could pre move this and I can't
pre-move that next one so quickly and
let's just do that because the knight
might have gotten to that square let's
do that get out of the bishop moves with
temp on my queen and now I could do this
but then there'd be a clean check get
that Queen nope let's open this up here
open that up okay let's take and pin
this Knight and then get my rook to c8
Knight move is gonna be brutal it's
gonna be very dangerous still dangerous
and there's a fork everything is hit
everything is hit right now this is big
trouble big trouble where does that mean
Oh kitchen sink time kitchen sink time
kitchen sink everywhere right here back
to tournament they resigned forty to
forty two thirty nine twenty seven
twenty minutes remaining
oh man no I didn't move here we go
Scandinavian okay let's come over here
oh are you kidding me oh there goes a
queen just like that just like that man
one blink don't blink man you can't have
blink in these tournaments
come on be tricky night gimme the tricky
nights calling all tricky nights I need
your help I need your help tricky nights
oh no no am I gonna have a laughing fit
now I feel it coming on oh no you don't
can I get this night please say it's
gonna be okay come on dark square
weaknesses fight fight fight fight no
trades what does that movie to do I
can't cancel it just try counseling
sorry I got loud right there it happens
though it happens oh just take this
night I just tried gasoline oh man you
can't cancel
Oh that nights gonna kill me he's
definitely gonna kill me can I get him I
got a defend like this can I get this
somehow oh hang on hang on hang on I see
hope I see oh I see hope oh no oh no no
no no what are we gonna have here give
me this prawn time situation 15 seconds
is there hope they're down a time no
don't you dare night Oh huh time time
time time time time
where you at time I can't do that I
dropped that pond 10 seconds no there's
another floor tricky nights tricky
nights tricky nights I need a fork uh
let's come back here their king is in a
nap I gotta get that guy he is a giant
pain no that was a mouse lip oh boy
that pond is fast tricky stuff tricky
stuff just run hunger donuts very 56:56
oh man
here we go confuse ray I gotta try an
you know do what I gotta do what
more bad jokes around the corner I gotta
try and confuse this guy Wow was that
clever what actually I better watch last
time I started talking about while that
was clever
I got scholars made it stay focused stay
focused Oh
throw your knight in here oh man I
thought for a second there was a crazy
battery and now there it kind of is oh
oh are they scared I'm scared no I'm not
scared I got a piece I got a piece Queen
has gone into pac-man mode
pac-man mode Queen trade clean trade
grab a pawn grab a bishop I'm a knight
I'm on the night still pigs pigs where
you at calling the pigs pigs grab a pond
push a pond they resigned back to
tournament 9090 87-72 mr. David is in
the house here he is in the house mr.
David is playing right now oh man
I dropped Queen and move what move to
why I didn't have to back up what was I
afraid of are you so afraid of that you
backed up like that tell me you mind
telling me that one I'm just gonna let
get myself in a fork I take up the pawn
yes they are my king is okay to run over
here I think oh man
Oh let's grab that pine uh uh uh just
move I'm not even moving oh man let's
come here take I don't want the F file
to open up actually it's okay let's do
this I'm gonna counsel Queen side I'm
not gonna take just yet it's pinned now
I'll take tricky checks
me too throw them in a pin Queen trade
Knight move I'd love to move that just
yet
during a pin Queen takes our rook takes
pawn oh here we go
actually I'm gonna go like this pawn
push next now that's got to be a nine
doesn't it does it they can work
themselves into a pin Knight takes Queen
f6 would be brutal vennett pawn push
having a clean trade man 17 seconds
tricky Knights Oh tricky Knights
everywhere man they are so dangerous do
you realize that dropping that palm but
he's out of play if he takes he's out of
play he's out of play and I my rook is a
pig he's a wild beast he's a beast he
went from he's been upgraded
he's been upgraded from pig to just a
beast he's a beast now some tricks fords
tricky Forks everywhere everywhere
everywhere
no stalemates they're down on time back
to tournament 110 107 90 halfway there
Jackson 88 Jackson 88 alrighty
are you gonna have an open Sicilian can
i grab that pond very quickly Knight b5
I back up I got that pawn central pond
an important pond the Queen's are off
build a center damage structure and go
forward with that
now your right here might be a little
bit of an inconvenience King d7 Bishop
f4 my knight could maybe go back to be
eight so much for that pawn push there's
gonna be a sack here to feel it I can
feel a sack coming up that tricky tricky
night get out of there no tactics get
out of there Knight can I get this file
there's also a pin against the rook pins
against the rook or even checks over
here pawn push now I get it
the pawn here don't take thin pieces
attack them that's what I did right
there I just dropped my rook
it's okay it's okay
now I'm gonna take this I'm on their
Bishop oh man why did I drop my rook
like that
now they dropped their bishop let's come
back over here this is really one where
I want to be get rid of this tricky
night he has got to go watch out for
windmills all right let's just take when
quickly anything anything pawn push pawn
push keep going
anything no stalemates anything but
stalemate
no stalemate oh they always have a pond
with anyhow mate in one two they'd have
a pond with back determined they're down
on time 132 120 no 140 140 127 110 okay
this guy's 107 he's the one that's in
second what's this guy's name the
exterminator or no well who is he it's
not the exterminator I get that from
yeah he's the exterminator play against
the Terminator I'm gonna get terminated
here okay
structural damage structural damage
where's my king wanna reside where does
he want to be where does he want to be
ah they were getting nervous
let's go pine pushing pushing time over
here Queen side okay we're gonna have a
bunch of exchanges let's come over here
King position King position double rooks
this is the only open file get there get
there King up no don't you dare do that
King position no not quite King position
soon soon whoa come over here King
position oh no I don't have a good King
position now I do
King position King position King
position King position give me that pawn
with check at the books off right here
take this and now I get the
I get that rook okay one king upon
endgame let's come over in this
direction now this and now let's keep
going okay
eventually I put them in stalemate now I
don't have to do it like that now okay
watch out for the sneakiness it's not
stalemate clean over here clean here
clean here that's me back to tournament
131 6145 13 games in 161 45 patriot
chess ten minutes remaining in this
tournament I have some catching up to
still do can I sneak in a quick kill
where are the quick kills okay oh that's
not working I'm gonna void that Queen
exchange so now that's not happening you
get that on that Bishop Castle kingside
you know you want to darn it alright I
guess we could go for this there might
be Forks Knight is really good on that
square just bump my king up I could have
taken the pawn right there
anything I think I could pretty much
cream of that now I might drop my rook
again might drop that rope again can I
get on that B file maybe let's take this
I think that that was there for a while
wasn't it kicked the night away and then
target C to target C - oh that was a
nice shot very nice oh no it actually
wasn't a good move I thought it was I
gave him too much credit right there I
should have taken this rook for awhile
how long was that there for anybody know
anybody keeping a journal in these
moments Wow
open this up undermine the pond that is
supporting the knight pin pieces pin the
knight chop here attack the knight
attack pin pieces no matter what even if
the rook defend
it's not defending that uh-oh this is a
problem how much time no time anything
that was actually me I didn't realize
160 150 whoa oh man
Wolfman number 2 I'm gonna call this
Totoro Vic Wolfman I'm coming at you I'm
coming at you now
coming at you oh it's made if the bishop
goes home go home go home he didn't go
home where you going now huh he's gonna
take my queen no he could do this Bishop
takes died do that I want that dark
square bishop man why does it always
have to be this difficult there's a
check I'm not afraid of that am i let's
do this
I get that rook I'm on the Queen and the
rook there are my knight why does it
have to be this crazy they're gonna take
my knight I get the rook but it's
dangerous it's very dangerous
Queens off please when in doubt just get
those Queens off this is not easy not
easy okay let me come over here and then
run away we're not going to run away to
right here before it's too late
let's take that and then this what's the
clock okay I'm okay with the clock get
out of that get out of that dangerous
stuff right there stop Bishop check ah
okay I got the rook
oh they got my bishop I want to make
sure I get this pawn come over here
what's the clock sit grab this punning
okay I want the night give me the night
I just give me that night please give me
this night okay he's gone haha
he's gone he is officially gone and
things are so much easier so much easier
when there is no night around back
determined to 1016 games in I have only
have 13 there's only six minutes
remaining
Wow where am I going with this opening
ok temple on the Queen pawn push I'm
gonna go here maybe they'll take my
bishop or not oh oh that's a stupid move
but I'm gonna do it so is that one no
it's not that's a good one the night is
still pinned why am i moving so slow
okay hang on Castle you know you want to
you can't castle now ah
where does my queen wanna be right here
right here my queen gonna get kicked
away let's take this and then I'm at
night they can't cast on either
direction
grab this what is the plan here man
they're being a pest they're putting up
good resistance no
it's close to mate if they do that can I
get this man they're defending like a
maniac here how much time is remaining
oh they did that ah that's pinned it's
15 seconds it's still pinned flights no
no but they resigned back determine what
to 230 230 190 17 games in its crazytown
5 minutes and change ok I didn't want to
do that definitely did not want to do
that I don't want to I don't want to
have the Queen exchange no Queen
exchange no Queen exchange can I get
all right so it's like I moved too slow
now I move too slow
oh they're doing that I take that and
then pinpoint f7 maybe I should have
taken it while I had the chance now I'm
going to rook check rook check that has
to be very uncomfortable I'm on em seven
take and then pawn push pawn push coming
up pawn push not coming up four minutes
remaining are they gonna resign quick
resigner
that's me or close to it where does that
mean they resigned back to term in 230
230 to ten I'd lose on tiebreaker and
you go to TV one first
are we gonna get paired up I think I'd
need to get paired up okay shut the door
on that bishop keep it closed support
that d4 pawn whatever you do just
support that d4 pawn on that bishop oh
oh oh oh this might be resign I get two
pieces quick Rosanna
this is bean I get two pieces are there
gonna be a clock Burnett oh no don't be
a clock burner the Queen has to go home
and then I take here and then here
otherwise Queen there okay I do this and
then do this then they're playing on
they are officially playing on 32
seconds remaining another piece ah man
okay guard that pawn on c2 why'd it take
like that get rid of that night actually
I don't care about my pawn on c2 anymore
it's a castle Queen here look right here
take Queens there to defend there's not
gonna there's no time remaining on this
so I'm just gonna do anything anything
anything at all anything at all right
here right here no time no time back
determine to 32 52 28 one more game in
AH I think it paired up with them I need
to get paired up I need a quick Hill 230
I need to get two more games in at least
213 two minutes 13 seconds two minutes
nine two minute nine ah here we go here
we go here we go um Brooke f1 are you
gonna take my bishop eventually okay
watch out for what I actually wasn't
even threatening anything keep pre
moving that it's not happening is it
there it is get that night out of there
and then take here and then a fork I'm
this squared Knight g5 stuff take the
knight if he goes there I get a fork in
there Knight up here if it's defended
okay that Knights hit he is officially
hit and I should have given a queen Shaq
that's not even doing anything now I
give a queen check maybe I could get a
mate are they gonna give up their rook
the King goes to the corner Knight check
you have to give up the rook pawn push
again is there right here oh yeah you
definitely have to give up the rook with
that Knight move because I'm on the
Queen I have this square covered after
Bishop takes rook takes this Knight is
covering it they missed that just want
to take that night actually anything
anything at all time burners time
burners that was probably a really bad
time burning to go with really bad
really bad
that was really I'm getting mated hold
their downtime that was really bad 250
270 26 seconds remaining
ah it's not happening it's not happening
unless top dog ace loses and I win this
one with like two seconds there's only
there's ten seconds remaining huh
I was almost really bad that was almost
really really bad forks forks forks
forks that was there I think I moved
sooner wasn't it it's complete kitchen
sink kitchen sink Oh
kitchen sink where are you at clean-out
ah night Fork they're not calling it why
aren't they calling it there it is no
they're not calling it yet
third place confetti I'm trying to get
second third place confetti
oh man striker strike me right there oh
man I did not want to see third place
confetti
oh good games ah I did as good as I
could man to 90 I wasn't even close to
65 250 ah man 20 out of 20 that was
excellent 1917 ah man this guy had a
buzzer beater he's saying he did have a
buzzer beater those are fun aren't they
I don't like losing to a buzzer beater
though I like I like being the one that
drains that three you know what I'm
talking about